we love talking to Bend Volant from the
Boston Globe here on the Rich Eisen show
bend Dan Hally here filling in for rich
are you down at the annual meeting there
in Arizona yeah Jen yeah and I love
talking to you Dan
it's a beautiful day here in Phoenix
this the sun is shining at 80 degrees
not there are worse places in the world
to be right now okay so you're in
Arizona you normally live in Boston
clearly the weather is better down there
I was making the case earlier that at
least from my standpoint from you know
working for NFL Network having gone to
the annual meeting aka the owners
meeting for three or four years in a row
one of the great events to really cover
when you have all that firepower under
one roof it is a pretty unique event
it's pretty special to be you know
you're at the bar hanging out at night
having a cocktail and you look to your
right there's John Elway and you look to
your left and there's Jerry Jones and it
is fun to rub elbows with these people
and you know a lot of obviously the NFL
is pretty big and and a lot of important
business gets conducted here over three
days but it's also a good good time to
unwind and good old warm place and let
the blood stand out a little bit network
with some cement FL people so this is
definitely one of the better events on
the calendar during the year we will get
to some of that business here in a
moment first what was the level of
surprise there around the league and
from the Patriots specifically when
Gronk announced his retirement the most
Gronk like way on Instagram yeah a
surprise for sure when I'm told he only
called Robert Kraft yesterday morning
and informed him that he was going to
retire and the Patriots they were kind
of proceeding okay he's probably gonna
announce it soon within a week or so and
then all of a sudden boom it's on
Instagram and and it seems like oh I
guess he's announcing it now so I think
in that sense it caused some people by
surprise does it happened very abruptly
and look we all we all know do this was
a possibility Rob Gronkowski during last
season didn't look like himself for most
of the year nine years of football
clearly taking their toll on him and
obviously last year he was already twin
with retirement so this was clearly on
the table but frankly I thought he was
going to be coming back the way
he ended the season he was so durable
and dependable over the last month and a
half of the season played a lot of snaps
from still making some big catches was
good in the run game for them was still
a very solid player so I thought he was
going to be coming back just but how
positive last season ended and so yeah I
was I was a little surprised that he
retired the timing also two weeks after
free agency started maybe the Patriots
had they known two weeks ago they would
have gone harder after a tight end maybe
someone like Jared cook so is you know
the timing of it is certainly surprising
and but but overall no one no one is too
shocked to see Gronk after all he's been
through finally walking away from the
game wouldn't be surprised if the
Patriots make a move maybe there's a
tight end there's two tight ends out of
Iowa no offense TJ Hawkinson who are
very talented expected to go in the
first round according to our lead draft
analyst Daniel Jeremiah over at NFL
Network Ben Volant on the phone with us
now from the Boston Globe how real was
that trade proposal to Detroit to go to
Motown and play there for Patricia yeah
it was real I think they had a deal on
the table where the Patriots would have
gotten the Lions first-round pick last
year and you know part of me wonders if
the Patriots really were just using it
as kind of leverage against Gronk to get
him to show up the offseason workouts in
the training camp because he was holding
out at the time so he and Belichick had
a meeting two days before the draft or I
believe so it kind of laid it all out on
the table and said look we had this
trade for Detroit here and we just need
to know your plans and cross that dope I
want to be back I only want to catch
passes from Tom Brady so all you know
I'll commit to this year and so then I
think the Patriots took that trade off
the table but it was there just because
they didn't know what Gronk was gonna do
last year and he was threatening
retirement all that and so you know even
today less than 12 hours after Gronk
retires his agent is going on ESPN this
morning and already planting the seeds
well maybe Gronk in December decides
that he wants to come back and the
Patriots Nino but he's already planting
the seeds for a grand comeback so I you
know I wouldn't maybe whole totally hold
my breath and see you know that Gronk is
fully retired and maybe he does
eventually come back but
seems like he's taking a lot of beatings
over the last nine years a lot of
surgeries and he's ready to hang up off
the prove on to the next phase of his
life of course that behooves Drew
Rosenhaus if Gronk comes back at some
point and and gets paid but Gronk's own
words to rosenhouse I'm done done done
what do you want to see Gronk do next I
want to see Grunk I mean I I'm sure
he'll you know just try to continue to
be a pitch man he's got some major
endorsement Dunkin Donuts Tide
you know national brands I'm sure he'll
still be a big presence around Boston
especially with dr. doughnut I'd love to
see him going to the WWE I think he's a
natural professional wrestling he's
already shown up at WrestleMania I know
he's good friends with John Cena and a
lot of those guys in in professional
wrestling he's just he's like a perfect
personality for that we'll see if he can
get into action movies I know Dwayne the
rock Johnson kind of has the market
cornered on being an action star right
now but not like Arnold Schwarzenegger
was you know a Shakespearian so if he
could do it maybe Gronk could do it too
that's sure I mean he only became he
only became the governor but initially
yeah all know that was in there or you
could say the same thing actually about
Sylvester Stallone who I would actually
equate closer to Kronk status era I
can't wait to see what it has my vote is
that he should take up residency in a
Las Vegas nightclub and become a host
/dj maybe you could have like a six
month span there fill in for the change
mothers didn't he can just be the height
man there you go bring him out on stage
and he straight takes off the shirt and
he dances around and gets everyone into
it that's that's an obvious move for him
so no go out there offensively for the
Patriots obviously they've won a Super
Bowl when Gronk has gone down in the
past on the field how big of an effect
is this gonna have for them and do you
think this expedites a Tom Brady
retirement at all no I don't think it'll
it alts me does that for Brady he's
gonna keep playing and he's been around
for so long now that he's used to
teammates coming and going you know
losing Gronk is still a significant loss
he's not the same Gronk from earlier in
his career
didn't quite have the same explosion and
power that he used to but he was still a
very good player like you know a plus
player you would say someone who played
a lot of snaps in that AFC Championship
game against Kansas City he played all
97 snaps and it wasn't just going and
running routes he was doing a lot of run
blocking very complete tight end you
don't see too many of those in today's
in FL a lot of the tight ends are
receiving tight ends now so Gronk was a
pretty rare player not the same dominant
guy but probably you know their number 2
or number 3 option in the passing game
and it's the timing of it you know maybe
they would have made a harder run at
Jarrett cook
if the Gronk was gonna retire two weeks
ago but you know there aren't too many
great options out there to replace him
the kids in the draft are the obvious
one Hawkinson and Fant both from Iowa
Bill Belichick goes way back with Kirk
Ferentz
the Iowa coach he was on Belichick staff
in Cleveland 25 years ago the Patriots
have five or six guys on their roster
from Iowa so they've obviously got their
eye on those two kids
what picking number 32 they're gonna
trade up most likely to make one of them
I don't know if either going to be there
you know there's there's always a trade
mark last year we didn't know who the
Patriots left tackle was going to be and
then all of a sudden they swung a try at
races got Trent Brown on draft weekend
and ended up being an unbelievable move
so there's still six months so they have
to play and Belichick there are a
million different ways for him to come
up with players but the easiest ways for
agency and they have missed out on the
few you know starting caliber tight end
possibly because of the timing of Gronk
retirement here yeah it's worked out
pretty well for Trent Brown that whole
situation didn't it yeah not bad he
comes with Patriots for one year you get
to start all 19 games win a Super Bowl
and then become the highest-paid
offensive lineman in league history and
go to the Raiders so I'd say you know
the Patriots have people say the
Patriots don't like to pay their players
which isn't always a fair criticism but
playing for the Patriots gets you paid
whether it's Malcom Butler or Chandler
Jones or Trey flowers and Trent Brown
they all got paid it just didn't come
from the Patriots so playing into
England still is a good opportunity yeah
Nate's older getting paid as well of
course when when he leaves New England
you look at so many guys
that roster and they have to take a
little bit less to potentially stay
there Julian Edelman is one who comes to
mind
gonna be interesting to see not only who
they draft but what other holes they try
and fill on that Patriots roster the
defending Super Bowl champs no longer
gonna have their I'm already gonna call
him a first-ballot Hall of Fame tight
end Ben Bowlin I hope that's okay with
you I'm good if you want to call him the
first ballot hall-of-famer even though
he only played nine years the man was as
dominant and his position as they come I
think he deserves first ballot and like
I said a rare specimen in today's NFL
where most of the tight ends are
receiving tight end and he was a true
inline you know grun blocking tight end
as well who was excellent in that phase
of the game so it won't be easy and
looked at Patriots Day don't just need
tight ends they wide receivers as well
they've Julian Edelman and a bunch of
guys who have never caught a pass in an
NFL game they lost out on Adam Humphries
they didn't really go after Golden Tate
too hard they they have 12 graphics and
so they're going to need to use them to
really add a youth infusion to the
offense and remake Tom Brady's passing
game or use them and make some trades
around draft weekend to try to find some
veteran but they got to hit Tom Brady
somehow because it's him and Julian
Edelman and some running backs and they
don't really have wide receivers or
tight ends right now
you're right Adam Humphreys going to
Mike rables Tennessee Titans another
slot guy similar to Julian Edelman
Golden Tate ending up with the New York
Giants Ben voluntarism enjoy the lobby
because I know it's gonna be
action-packed please say hi to some of
my NFL Network friends I will definitely
do that thank you for having me on today
then alright Ben Bowlin from the Boston
Globe one of the best in the business
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience